le bruit des machines qui redémarre des
bouteilles qui se succèdent et les
cartons qui se remplissent jean-jacques
vraiment respire sa production viticole
peut repartir
ces trois derniers mois ont été
compliqués fermeture des fameux chr
cafés hôtels restaurants ralentissement
des exportations
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure des comptes il
ya des gens ça sera très dur puisqu'il
ya des gens travail en chr ce qu'on dira
pas ça pour ça mais 80 % de perte bon
bien sûr les gens ont travaillé les
réseaux sociaux ont fait du drame et
donc ils sont arrivés à écouler un petit
peu de la marchandise tout ce que nous
demandons aujourd'hui c'est surtout un
allègement des charges sociales parce
que c'est ce qui pèse le plus sur les
entreprises mais pas simplement report1
jaillir il faut qu'il s'est passé
l'épongé au moins jusqu'à la fin de
l'année parce que ce qui n'est pas vendu
ne va pas être vendus dans les mois qui
viennent donc s'il ya des pertes de
chiffres d'affaires et bien sûr que
ressent plus difficile donc pour joindre
les deux bouts
jean jacques bréban est l'un des plus
gros négociateurs de la région paca 9
millions de bouteilles commercialisées
chaque année dont 40 % consacrés à
l'export vers les états unis ou bien
encore la chine
quant à l'asie c'était un marché en
devenir en août et est en train d'y
travailler
c'est sûr que tout a été stoppé que nous
espérons que quand même
les prix ne vont pas aller à la baisse
ce n'est bon pour personne
mais je veux dire aujourd'hui il faut
que tout le monde gagne sa vie le
producteur je dire comme le négociant et
si nous travaillons ensemble pour
maintenir des prix à bien nous sortirons
beaucoup moins se réinventer se
diversifier laurent bunan n'a pas chômé
pendant cette période de confinement
alors que touristes français et
étrangers en déserté son domaine de 60
hectares des acheteurs 2.0 ont fait leur
apparition ce qui a permis de limiter
une perte de 50% du chiffre d'affaires
la progression sur internet a été
excellent exponentielle on a fait sur un
incertain week-end on a eu jusqu'à 250
commandes sur notre site internet ce qui
ne s'était jamais arrivé parce que avec
les transporteurs on a trouvé quand même
quelques accords et on a réussi à à
livrer un peu partout en france et en
europe
nos vins aux particuliers l' ouverture
des bars-restaurants la règle des 100 km
lever les vignerons espère désormais
reprendre au plus vite les chemins des
salons et autres foires